now the big news is from The Daily
Caller top Anheuser-Busch Marketing
Executives behind boycott are no longer
employed the top two Anheuser-Busch
Market Executives were placed on leave
amid the company shakeup no longer work
for the brand a source inside and
azerbush confirmed in texts obtained by
The Daily Caller on Tuesday group vice
president for marketing Daniel Blake and
Bud Light marketing vice president
Alyssa heinershide are gone gone
according to obtained text messages with
a current Regional head of marketing the
caller is granting anonymity to the
source to discuss lengthy fraught
internal company policy quote to my
understanding if we publicly announce
the word fire it opens up potential for
them to sue us that's why we said leave
of absence the source that in text
message obtained by the caller the
wholesalers would have had an absolute
Heyday with leadership if they didn't
remove her the source inside the company
also said to be fair Daniel Blake was
actually awesome I think he was just
caught in the crossfire but also he did
hire her so that's a fault wholesalers
were told they are both gone for good by
leadership during in-person
conversations they already shifted all
their direct reports to new people and
the head of marketing The Source added
another text message obtained by the
caller I'll tell you why this is
important
what we thought was going to happen
there's a hubbub some Bubble Up In The
Press after a couple days or a week
sales return to normal the boycott
falters they announced they're coming
back from their leave of evidence or or
just don't announce anything and they
just slide back in their positions and
everything resumes and they keep on
keeping on but that's not what happened
what happened so far is that three
months on Bud Light sales continue to
get worse and now they've officially
terminated these individuals Starbucks
just had a strike last week because
they're telling people to take down
Pride decorations targets stock value is
collapsing and a bunch of other brands
are reeling because ladies and gentlemen
get what go broke is becoming more and
more powerful
yeah absolutely you'd love to see it I
had a similar expectation when this all
began I thought you know people are
going to stop drinking bud light for a
little while but they're gonna they're
gonna go back to it I I think that when
conservatives have tried boycotts in the
past they haven't really stuck to them
and of course this situation is a little
bit different and one key detail I was
missing is that you don't have to be a
conservative to be disgusted by this
kind of thing there's a large subsection
in this country which still finds a man
in a dress to be very off-putting and so
even without having any kind of
organization or political ideology
behind it people said I'm not drinking
that anymore I just I I disagree a
little bit I think the average person
does not care about a man in a dress and
that's why it was tolerated for so long
what they care about is one it was
marketing beer to kids and two we're
seeing more and more of the grooming
stuff parents started seeing books in
schools that were teaching children
about adult explicit content and now
what's happening is it's causing a
backlash that's encompassing more than
just the core issue right so when a
parent sees a book like this book is gay
which which Ian purchased and it taught
it teaches children how to use adult sex
apps there's a backlash and everything
it's it's collateral damage so for a
long time you get a guy in a dress what
happens the average default Urban
liberal or Suburban liberal or whatever
type didn't care and I said I don't care
what these people are doing in their in
their own homes they're liberals right
so they're like do whatever you want
live and live
then these books come out come in these
schools now they see it and they
associate all of it with each other
that's why now in Bud Light it's not
just this even Bud Light sponsoring
Toronto Pride where you've got naked men
you know gyrating in front of children
so people see that and they're just like
all of it gone don't want it no sorry
bye-bye I I agree with you that the
grooming and all of the perversity
that's come into the Limelight in a way
that it wasn't before is also factoring
into people's decision to boycott but I
would say that people have traditionally
and historically still been off put by
seeing a man in a dress I would say that
that was the case
um all the way up until now no right
right right like
and Brands weren't using them as mascots
I was looking at old photos from
Atlantic City in the 20s and people are
out in summer wearing suits yeah like it
was like yes people were offended by
people who didn't wear the uniform so
like even up for for a long period of
time we got to a point where a guy in
drag a person a cross-dresser male or
female or whatever was for for a long
time socially completely unacceptable
but with the liberal period in the past
20 or so years they said ah you live in
the live do do your thing I don't care
but what I'm saying now is yes people
may not like it but they tolerate it and
said we don't care we tolerate this now
they're not tolering it at all yeah no
no I agree I guess my main point is just
that through that period where people
were tolerating it it wasn't because
they didn't find it off-putting they
were just willing to allow it to happen
somewhere else right right right right
yeah and now that it's affecting them
the pendulum is starting to stay in the
other direction yeah
so then what's the end result are we
gonna see
more Brands back off did we win is this
is this the the get well go broke as the
the the the Brick that got pulled from
the tower that causes the total collapse
look I I mean I personally think it's
gonna depend on the brand unfortunately
I mean I think that there's if Ben and
Jerry's put Dylan Mulvaney on a carton
of ice cream it people wouldn't bat an
eye I mean because that's their customer
base right I don't agree I I just I just
don't know uh because that's that that's
how far out they are for Bud Light
and for most mainstream corporate
mainstream corporations families
especially touching on exactly the issue
that you just mentioned which is people
don't want this stuff shoved in their
face they don't they're tired of it and
so like for 20 years people tolerated
RuPaul's drag shows and all this other
stuff okay well yeah they're off doing
their own thing in their own life and
and but now they're they're doing
exactly what's happening but I think
like I I just with a bit with a brand
that is extremely liberal like Ben and
Jerry's I don't know with everything
else I think not on Ben and Jerry's Ben
and Jerry's a gas station brand yeah Ben
Jerry's is like Bud Light sure they do
kooky things you know like resist or
whatever but no one cares when they walk
in to grab a pint of ice cream they want
cookie dough and brownies that's all
they care about so when Bud Light became
political
in this particular way people were just
like nope not buying it and I think it's
because it's now affecting them Ben and
Jerry's does a lot of political stuff
but let's be real a guy walking into a
gas station for some cookie dough ice
cream doesn't care if it's if it's
Haagen-Dazs or Ben and Jerry's maybe he
likes Ben and Jerry's because it got
bigger cookie dough chunks that's about
it so if they started I I do think of
Ben and Jerry's put Dolan Mulvaney on
the carton it would sell a lot less I I
agree I agree this just crossed my mom
but I think a big mistake that Bud Light
made Anheuser-Busch is Dylan's not
really I mean I'm not going to claim if
he's trans or not but he's a he's an
actor and and he's doing Camp he's very
he's spoken outward that he's like
making fun of the whole process so it's
not like a real trans woman that's like
look we're identifying gender dysphoria
this person is like we're in support of
this community it's Dylan Mulvaney he's
a crazy actor he's like so they they
almost yeah mocked trans rights and
transgenderism by using Dylan as their
spokes model well this is the crazy
thing to me I think I think Dylan's
intention is to insult trans people
like I I say it all the time I don't
know how you get anything else from that
there was like the recent video where
Dylan is on the red carpet and Tony the
Tiger comes out and Dylan starts
panicking and freaking out I'm like
could you imagine if if a white man like
put on blackface and went around and
started hooting and hot like Dylan
Mulvaney
is is a comedian and actor who has has
done a bunch of ridiculous things like
The Price is Right video running around
and and rolling around on the ground
it's all it's it's like shock jock Borat
level stuff for real and so I I you you
look at these videos that Dylan's
produced come on let's be real Dylan's
singing about having a bulge is just to
insult trans people I and and you know
we had that uh that left his guest on
Friday Phil Labonte the other night was
saying her whole thing was literally
just whatever Tim says we're gonna we're
gonna say the opposite and that's what
ends up happening delmo then he comes
out puts on this performance that's
insulting and demeaning to women and
trans people we criticize Dylan for
doing it so they defend Dylan
interesting yeah I mean we're I I don't
make the same distinction that you guys
do I I view all of this the same way but
I'm curious about how the transgender
Community or people who identify as
transgender have responded to Dylan
prior to the public backlash well look
you have there are prominent uh
personalities who are trans who speak
out against these people yeah and there
is among transgender people there's a
left and a right as well so it's it's I
I don't think you can you can you can
hit it all with one broad brush stroke
you know what I mean clearly is a unique
character that is is putting on a
performance and has even said this Dylan
Mulvaney did not come outside they
weren't trans but did say they wanted to
move Beyond being identified as a trans
person something something that effect
for sure no I I don't disagree with you
guys at all that Dylan is a particularly
obnoxious example and I I don't disagree
that people who identify as trans have a
wide variety of political views where
I'm saying I don't draw the distinction
is I think all of it's insulting to
women I think all of it is a caricature
of Womanhood oh yeah no I'm saying that
Dylan's insulting trans people on top of
it like you know you can you can take a
look at um many look I'll I'll shout out
Blair white and I'll shout out Contra
points a a a I guess Blair is considered
conservative I don't know where where
Blair stands and Contra points is
considered liberal they're both serious
people you can disagree with them you
can you can uh have arguments around
their ideologies or the way they live
their lives but they're both serious
people who present arguments Dylan
Mulvaney puts high heels on in the woods
runs around and then sings about having
a bulge which just demeans and insults
trans people
like I just it's Borat so that makes me
think that maybe Gene you were onto
something that if if companies were to
go with you know utilizing
transgenderism as a marketing tactic but
not going for the campy clownish uh
people as their as their spokespeople
and they actually find like genuinely
you know trans people that are like
maybe they've been suffering or whatever
and they want to elevate that Community
somehow I could see that actually not be
destroying a company maybe actually
helping I mean I just go back to the
RuPaul
RuPaul has a show on what e or whatever
and how to show for decades RuPaul's
Drag Race show and all these other
things and and so you have you have
these examples of this stuff happening
where you have a base that is
conditioned in acculturated to this
lifestyle into this this stuff which
which with none of it I I agree with to
be clear
um quite the opposite but when you take
a brand like Bud Light yeah or you take
something like anything I mean take a
Ford Mustang if they if Ford decided
we're going to advertise their new
Mustang with with Dylan Mulvaney didn't
they did Ford do an advertisement with
Dylan no no they did they did a pride
rate who did the price seriously yeah
okay
somebody did do I I think someone might
have done a rainbow truck but also to be
clear there's something about the
rainbow that puts a layer of abstraction
over it I I don't think there was an
actual picture of somebody like Dylan
Mulvaney associated with it yeah in
2022.4 did it wow thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time